first let me lament the fact that we can
ask any one of us in any room I don't
care what age you are provided you
you're done with school and ask how many
teachers of all the teachers you've had
in life for most people that would be
like scores of teachers you know is it
seventy eighty a hundred teachers some
maybe as few as 50 or 40 but still in
the high tens ask among all your
teachers how many made a singular impact
in your life how many changed you in
fundamental important ways unfortunately
the answer to that question is almost
always no more than this two three at
most five for me that numbers three and
that's not unusual so what is what gives
here by the way they wouldn't have to be
science teachers I'm talking my teachers
in any subject and what makes those
teachers special is that you could have
no interest in the subject going in and
you come out and it's the most
interesting thing you've ever heard in
your life those teachers convey
something special within their students
enthusiasm and excitement a passion so
one of my great laments is that
education today seems to have be less
about passion and more about process
more about tactic or technique uh but I
don't know anybody who said boy I love
that teacher he or she gave a really
good homework set or boy that was the
best class I ever took because those
exams were awesome that's not what
people want to talk about that's not
what influences people in one profession
or another it's it's how well the
instructor imparted their passion for
their subject in their students and just
extend this to the sciences we all know
people who would turn off by science
because they had a bad teacher that's
the worst case the teacher the teacher
now had the opposite effect of what
education ought to be so I don't know -
do you do we rifle through the
educational system and like get rid of
those teachers and clone the others I
don't have an easy silver bullet there
but I do know but that shouldn't prevent
me from citing at least part of what
problem is I want to see more impassion
teachers than are currently out there
and if you can light a flame and a
student that's that's half half the work
[Music]